alors vous étiez le 19 mars 2012 dans
cette école juive mais où mohamed merah
fait irruption armé jusqu'aux dents
c'est un massacre épouvantable il ya
quatre morts aujourd'hui vous
reconstruisez je pense que c'est plus
important pour vous c'est d'essayer
d'oublier mais est-ce qu'on peut oublier
un tel événement c'est impossible
on n'oublie pas on apprend à vivre avec
au quotidien forcément qu'il ya des
craintes des angoisses parle souvent de
stress post traumatique et c'est
exactement ça mais on apprend on apprend
à se reconstruire à se relever
moi pour ma part j'essaye d'être actif
acteurs au quotidien pour justement
rendre hommage aux victimes pour pas
qu'on les oublie surtout il ya eu en
tout 200 sont dit victime depuis depuis
2002 c'est cette journée le commence
normalement vous êtes élève
j'en rêve je suis élève dans cette école
je suis même interne au sein de cette
école donc je vis sur place à la journée
elle commence de façon tout à fait banal
et puis je me rends à la synagogue pour
débuter ma prière aux alentours de 8h et
j'entends des coups de feu alors à ce
moment-là je sais pas que c'est des
coups de feu je pense que c'est des
pétards qui éclate je regarde à travers
la porte vitrée et puis je le vois
rentrée et pour moi c'est pas du tout un
tueur qui est là mais un coursier ou
autre et puis encore des coups de feu et
des coups de feu et des coups de feu
puis je regarde j'essaye de voir ce qui
se passait un peu d'agitation et puis là
il ya la cpe qui arrive en hurlant et en
criant il ya un tireur dans l'école ya
un tireur dans l'école cas chez vous
donc je sort à sa rencontre et je
réceptionne informations et puis je vais
voir le directeur de l'école et puis je
lui dis monsieur monsonego il ya un tir
à bout 1 école c'est pas une blague
et c'est ce qui la corse et de plus
touchés en plus c'est le sait le papa de
myriam monsonego qui a été qui a été tué
ouais aujourd'hui vous aujourd'hui vous
êtes marié peut être pensez vous du
matériel est d'accord célibataire mais
je me suis reconstruit jeu encore une
fois voilà j'essaye vraiment des
tracteurs de faire des choses pour
perpétuer leur mémoire je suis
actuellement sur un projet de livre ce
sujet là qui est quasiment terminée pour
rendre hommage aux victimes
quel message vous voulez faire passer
aujourd'hui j'aimerais qu'on
on essaye de se souvenir des victimes
parce que c'est souvent le nom des
assassins qui est mis en lumière
malheureusement et je pense qu'il faut
qu'on fasse l'effort au quotidien de se
remémorer de se rappeler de qui étaient
les personnes qui ont été touchées qui
ont été les victimes
et puis qu'on n'oublie pas on oublie pas